all right let's get ready for the worst
at talk ever I mean we prepared 30
minutes ago I want to be clear I love to
be here with you all but I wanted to
hear not to tell my story but to tell
the story of the amazing people of
Puerto Rico that came together to feed
the people of Puerto Rico my name is
Jose Andres and you know I love to feed
the field but even more enough to feed
the many here right after the hurricane
like we've done many times before after
earthquake in Haiti Oh Sunday or others
I had this sense of urgency to be there
and to try to feel one person and always
you have crazy friends that they want to
join you in those impossible endeavors
I'm always surrounded by amazing friends
that only help me to be better Nate came
next to me this was a Monday and this is
what we found the destruction you found
to be one more hurricane but this
destruction was real more than 95
percent of the electricity in the island
was gone every single electric pole was
gone all the cell towers were gone
you couldn't communicate with anybody
you couldn't find anybody in the moment
you move away from someone even in
someone we had issues trying to use our
cell phones and what I found was that
the island was hungry and that people
didn't had or money because ATMs were
not working or their cards which are
electronic for food stamps they couldn't
use it in their supermarkets or there
was no food or gas or clean water to
cook they need and the audience II of
now was real and eius was able to get
into a meeting
at FEMA where many of the main NGO
partners we're having a conversation
about how to feed the island in the
weeks to come but the urgency was right
now in this minute in this second and we
almost had three million people that
needed to be fed so we began doing what
we do best we went to see the sources of
food and I was able to see that the
private industry actually was ready and
prepared and thriving but somebody a
FEMA was not able even to be aware of
that and what we did was use fine
kitchens Jose Enrique one of my favorite
men in the whole war one of the great
restaurants in someone where before
landing I began calling all the chefs of
Puerto Rico and everybody was like let's
not plan let's not meet let's start
cooking and that's what we did we began
feeling the people of Puerto Rico on a
Monday on a Monday with 8,000 Mills
sancocho an amazing a steel with corn
and you can pork by Sunday we were doing
25,000 by Sunday we already didn't only
use the restaurant but we rented the
garage the parking lot right across we
began bringing food trucks and a rice
and chicken pie operation and
refrigerators and volunteers began
coming why because everybody wants to
find a place to help a place to do
something this is how we began our first
delivery the hospital's nobody was
feeding the nurses and the doctors and
we began feeding our first bro yet
Hospital carolina all of the sudden
every single hospital was calling us we
need food so we can feed our 24/7
employees taking care of the sick and
the elderly and the people in need and
then the place was too small we were
receiving orders every time we got one
guest one customer we never stopped
serving them because we wanted to make
sure that we were able to be stabilizing
any place we were kind of joining any
city any Hospital any elderly home every
time we made contact with them we kept
serving them food day after day so
needed to grow we move into the big
coalition 25,000 Mills became 50,000
Mills became all of the southern the
biggest restaurant in the world we we
were making close to 70,000 meals a day
from one location alone volunteers
volunteers began showing up by the
hundreds at one point we got more than
7,000 volunteers that were at least one
hour or more with us and any given
moment more than 700 people at once you
saw that we began creating a movement a
movement that had very simple idea
everybody could rely behind let's feed
the hungry and we began making food that
people could recognize know things that
come from a faraway place in plastic
bags that you open and you cannot even a
smell we began making we began making
the foods that people feel home people
in these moments they had this urgency
of feeling they are alive that somebody
cares one meal at the time he didn't
only became something used to bring
calories to their bodies calories that
they needed but they needed something
else they wanted to make sure that you
and you and you and you that you were
carrying that we were sending the
message that we are with you give us
time we are trying to fix this that's
what we found every time we will began
doing in the communities fresh fruit
began coming even when in FEMA they were
asking me who say how are you able to
get the food simple by calling and pain
and getting
we began we began feeling people in
someone before you knew we were feeling
the 78 municipalities all across the
island we needed a plan one kitchen
alone was not going to fit the island I
went to FEMA they kicked me out with
eight armored guards and ak-47s I told
them I want eighteenth kitchens around
the island guess what three days ago we
reach our 18th kitchen around Puerto
Rico people began being fed volunteers
keep showing up we never had any system
to deliver the food people will tell me
sure we had the system the entire island
of Puerto Rico was the perfect delivery
system anybody with a trach wanted to
help anybody going from A to B was for
us the way to be bringing hope and a
plate and a whole meal to anybody
we began finding amazing systems to do
these food trucks can amazing food
trucks we began learning not use the
place than either day the the food but
the number the the number of the
apartment 92 year old veteran that was
surrounded by water
we began giving not only hope to people
but knowing their names
checking day after day making sure that
those elderly people will never ever
again feel alone in a moment of
disrepair and we began go into the
deeper areas places that all of the
sudden the bridges were broken but we
had to go because was easy to stay in
San Juan we had to go to those places
that actually they really need us and we
kept going and people kept waiting for
us because they knew that we will always
show up because we will never leave them
alone children
the foot tracks became our angles and
the foot tracks kept sending ho but we
saw we needed more Vieques and Culebra
two islands far away from the island
somebody had to be feeding them within
only bring food and make a hot kitchen
operation in Vieques and bring daily
food to Culebra
we brought the first water purification
system to the island of Vieques where we
could be filtering 1 gallon per minute
all of the sudden big problems become
very simple low hanging fruit solutions
only by doing not planning and meeting
in a very big building and then we found
creative ways we needed helicopters we
asked with God we needed planes we asked
we pay and we got we kept sending food
to those places that really were in need
and a simple idea just become powerful
volunteers will go to the edges of the
island all of this island was a movement
the themes of war central kitchen will
be received with prayers with songs with
claps with hugs with its miles we were
able to connect in so many corners when
I tell you that even the National Guard
began calling as we caused our national
poor guys guards big heroes in the
moment of chaos they couldn't get a
simple humble plate of hot food and
partnership show up mercy corpse HSI
from homeland security partnerships that
they didn't happen calling the top they
happen in the hotel room they happen in
the middle of the street they happen in
the middle of the mountains we saw that
by working together we can even reach
more people partnerships that happens by
logic and the urgency of now is put to
the service of the people when we have
emergency relief organizations we cannot
be planning about how to give eight a
month from now we have to be ready to
start giving help in the second after
something happens and children
were fed and all of this island the
island while it's still in a very
special moment where everything is
fragile we saw that an NGO like ours we
didn't want to break the private sector
that already a small restaurants were
being open that somehow normalcy
whatever normalcy means to the emperor
Rico was happening we began trying to be
sending the message we need to start
moving away from the places that they
are already stabilized and keep
concentrating in the areas that really
need help people of Puerto Rico two
million minutes okay let me translate
this to you twenty almost 28 days later
more than ten foot drugs more than seven
thousand volunteers eighteenth kitchens
we serve more than two million meals
and you guys coming here that you should
be proud because we know many of you you
are part of the change but the change is
only going to happen if after we leave
this amazing conference we put the
amazing ideas and inspiration that we
get and we believe that nothing is
impossible and we put our know-how to
the service of those in need I arrived
to an island use trying to feed few
people and I saw a big problem and all
of the sudden the people of Puerto Rico
saw the same problem as me and only we
did one thing we began cooking and so
the people of Puerto Rico and the chef's
opera Rico in a moment of disrepair
began bringing hope know by meeting
know by planning but with only one
simple idea let's start cooking and
let's start feeding the people of Puerto
Rico thank you
so so just a couple of quick questions
because I think some folks would be
interested to hear so as you said you
came first time tried to got on the
ground went to the government command
center started to have some meetings
with people and they weren't very
receptive this is great this is good my
talk was is the first start with a
follow-up in the history of Ted I feel
so good so tell us tell us why what were
some of the challenges and then when
when you notice they started they
started coming to you to ask you in
we're gonna be asking everything from
Red Cross or Salvation Army
but the idea is I donated before to
those organizations and they are the big
organizations and maybe the problem is
that we're expecting too much from them
it's not like they didn't do what they
were supposed to do is that the
perception is that that's what they do
but all of the signs you cannot get into
mommy ladies and wash your hands and you
say somebody else is going to be picking
the top we had a simple problem that had
a very simple solution this was not a
faraway country or the Green Zone in
like that this was American soil a
beautiful place corporal Rico with
hundreds thousands of restaurants and
people willing to help but all of the
time we had people hungry and we then
had to plan how to feed them in the
short term so yes FEMA tour degree was
thinking about how to feed the people
Red Cross did I had the right answers
because South and Baptist Church the
biggest food organization in America my
heroes they were never called to Puerto
Rico when you see a Red Cross delivering
food in America after a hurricane is
south and Baptist Church doing it we
then had that in Puerto Rico Salvation
Army came and asked me 420 meals on a
Wednesday rainy night for a local
elderly chopped
I love to help Salvation Army but in my
world they are the ones supposed to be
helping us to answer those calls of help
Thursday morning is when I wake up super
worried that actually we didn't had a
plan to feed the island and some people
would say maybe you are making the
problem bigger than it was well we had
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of organizations knocking on
our door asking for a tray of food so if
that's not proof that the need was real
we cannot be feeling people in America
anymore with MREs or something like you
open and you know it was given to these
little cut a little bit of those same
food and then I gave them the chicken
arise we made and they went for the
chicken arise they don't even need that
themselves we can't feed humanity for a
day or two or five but those memories
cause like 12 14 15 $20 to the American
taxpayer it's okay for certain moments
during battle but not to be keep feeling
Americans for weeks and weeks of weeks
when actually you can be hiring the
local private business community to do
the same job better creating local jobs
helping the local economy to come back
and in the process making sure that
everything was going to go back as
normal as quick as possible that's what
we began cooking you were there with me
and that's why we spend every single
dollar we had in our credit cards if
Amex is listening to this please a
discount will be appreciated
orbiter so so what's what's the
situation now you know it's been a month
you said there's been some some
improvements in the San Juan and focus
on the areas outside but obviously
there's still major challenges and yeah
what's next so what's next is we slowly
began going down after more or less FEMA
let us know that they thought they had
everything under control and we were no
any longer needed but you know you only
believe everything so much we we move
from the big place you saw 60,000 meals
a day it was to another one as big but
more strategically located also cheaper
where we're going to be making 2025
thousand meals a day and then we are
living for five six kitchens
strategically located around the island
very high up in the mountains in the
poor areas we got a lot of data we know
who is using as naps with using food
stamps the the the cards and we know who
has them and we know who is using them
so in the parts of the island and nobody
is using them those are the parts of the
island we are going to be focusing our
efforts so it's amazing how sometimes
simple data can give you a clue of who
are the people in need so we went to
town called madhavan's beautiful the
best chicken restaurant in the history
of mankind you should all travel
tomorrow it sounds good so I saw that
chicken we were bringing some witches I
stopped I was with this homeland
security officers we ate the chicken I
left to drop these sandwiches in this
other place called San Lorenzo San
Lorenzo was critical because the bridge
was broken and so was an island inside
the island a little community surrounded
by water everybody told us is a disaster
down there we drop the sandwiches I went
back to my ovens and I thought you know
if he's a disaster sandwiches is not
enough
I bought hundred twenty chickens with
joka and with rice and we went back to
that broken bridge we crossed the river
water up to everywhere we arrived with
the 120 chickens we drop the food and
they come
we were very thankful but they told us
we're okay we don't need more food we
have gas we have money we have good food
and our water is clean take care of the
other communities around us that they
are in more need you see
communication is key in these scenarios
we can be relying now to fake news or we
can be having the real information that
we can make a smart decisions to really
take care of the true issues that's what
we are doing well it was an amazing
operation and to witness it firsthand
and to play a small role you made it
happen
at at its peak I think you were up to
about a hundred and fifty thousand meals
per day across the island which is which
is pretty incredible and I think at the
same time really sort of setting a model
for how this can be done hopefully
moving forward right I mean I think
that's one of the big learnings out of
this this is possible you know people
can replicate this pattern but I'm gonna
stop coming to watch TED Talks because
then you got ideas that anything
happened then my wife told me man you
told me you were going to cook thousand
meals a day I can leave you alone for a
day but I hope that wasn't her kitchen
you know one thing we did I then say I
pick up the phone and I began calling
people people that they thought had this
Purdy's that could help us so I pick up
the phone and I call a company called
Bon Appetit feed la when I bet is one of
the big catering companies they do food
for Google and for arenas and for air
out of California they belong to a
bigger group called compass and I told
them you know what I need cooks and I
need cooks that can do volume and that
can do good-quality volume in less than
24 hours I began getting people and
chefs at one point we got 16th of the
best chefs that America can offer you
see America is an amazing hard country
that always is sending their best but
we've been learning over the years is
that those chefs of America are gonna be
playing a war
and how we're gonna be feeling America
and maybe other parts of the world in
times of need what we need to start is
bringing the right expertise where
disparate is is needed sometimes I have
a feeling like with FEMA we're bringing
the wrongest Purdy's in the area that is
not even the people of him are great
people the men and woman are smart they
are prepared but they live under decent
missing her keep your a middle
organizational chart that everybody
falls out of their own weight we need to
be empowering people to be successful
what we did was a flatter organizational
chart where everybody was owning the
situation and we all made quick
decisions to solve the problems on the
spot another round of applause for Jose
at this
[Applause]